Let's start by considering the left side. To make this no longer a fraction, we
need to multiply both sides to the equation by its denominator. However, doing
that alone doesn't help us with the right side. To deal with this fraction, we
need to multiply both sides by the quantity 4x plus 2. Now let's see what that
leaves us with. On the left side, multiplying by 7 minus 3x gets rid of the
denominator, but then we still are multiplying by this other factor. I made a
mistake and forgot to write our parentheses around this entire factor we're
multiply by. That's super important, and clearly, it's very easy mistake to
make. On the right-hand side, since we're multiplying by 4x plus 2, that deals
with the denominator. But we still have a factor of 7 minus 3x. Wonderful. This
is our final answer.